welcome everybody to another business QA
on league of legends i'm going to play
league of legends with jason jrs fonseka
in the house and answer some business
questions with rishi kept TV how you
doing machine i'm happy i'm doing i'm
happy i'm a little bit tired today but
not tired like I'm not excited to be
here but not tired that you're you're
not it was a delirious but we movie the
other day give you guys I think I we I
yeah was I tired all week that's kind of
sad I don't need to be tired all day
this week but it has been a shaker
intense last week so but I love you guys
i'm happy to be here all the time
whether i'm tired or not alright well
what's in the cup today i got my cup of
whoops fellow my banish my spanish
coffee my cafe con leche and and I'm
feeling a cup of present one of the
things I'm working on break it right now
is to just be more present and not not
fallen to like future thinking or
thinking too much in the past but like
being really present so that's what I'm
working on today I know and continually
hopefully a cup of present I like it
come a present I like it um cool we'll
shout out in the twitch chat we got last
minute Louie Jen so much believe team is
me rishi cup of course rise online we'll
see what everybody else shows up I've
got my usual five drinks my my Zen no my
yogi this is the last yogi tea in the
box so i may have to find something else
for the next time thank you the yogi
message of the day is act don't react
like I like it ties into it no crisis
business philosophy where you're being
proactive in planning what you're doing
instead of just reacting to other
people's emergencies mm-hmm my pumpkin
spice latte courtesy of junior eyes wow
you got like that old deal today it's
it's it's on it's on Jay's going black
jeans going back to the mid experiment
to the support Sona experiment we're
going to chalk up to a test and we're
going back to our tried and true and
we'll see how it goes well let's get
into it what's our first question ok
cool and I'm sorry I just have to say I
mean how cool is it that you have like
every day a message in your cup I mean
that's just coolest thing ever I like it
I wrestler yeah I didn't even notice the
first time first time first tons of
times I guess it didn't know it is but I
like the X a little bit of love and on
them now i look forward to getting my
little message love it alright so we're
going to start off actually with not a
question it's just an awesome comment i
think it's going to uplift you evan i
think it's going to list everybody in
believe nation because this is a just
inspirational story about how how you're
making an impact so this is from debbie
and she says Evan I just don't know what
you know that I love your videos and
find you so inspirational she says
believe has always been my motto ever
since I was dished ever since I ditched
my corporate NYC job on nine eleven 2001
and followed my passion of painting I've
been spending I've spending I have been
spending the last few months pivoting my
local decorative painting business into
a growing online art business at the
same time I'm still pursuing my local
NYC market interior designers and trying
to find high-end collectors for my
abstract coastal sophisticated paintings
my new website is almost ready to go I'm
going to start a facebook ads and every
time I get an email from you it
Rihanna's
and keeps me motivated to keep trucking
along i believed in my journey and
hoping to reach my goal of selling
10,000 of art ten thousand dollars worth
of art per month so i can continue to
give back but in a much bigger way to
help those that need it thanks for doing
what you do and when I think I can't do
it starting from almost nothing I am
reminded that you said in the beginning
you had no listeners or followers but
you never stopped that's always in my
mind thank you for allowing me to
continue to believe debbie mumm regards
debbie a lot of love there I love that
isn't that beautiful that's awesome
thank you debbie i love it too because
yes i love it too just because um I
think it's inspirational to hear someone
who who you know obviously 911 caused a
lot of people to reevaluate a lot and
sounds like you know she really made
changes that felt right for her and I
just like hearing that someone took that
leap and and actually is you know did it
I mean so many people do that so I think
that's so cool how can we help debbie
get to 10,000 a month in sales for her
art so we can so she can continue to
help people what do you think every some
more value for reward the word it yeah i
think that that's an awesome awesome
thing so what she's trying to do online
is she said ten thousand dollars of art
per month well I I would want to just
find out more about maybe what her
market is i don't i don't know Evan
you're gonna have to answer that one
because I I know you've got so much more
knowledge in the art out of progress
your visual art
alright cool i'll go uncle on it um I'm
something exciting just happened in the
game too which is which I want to tell a
quick story about at home so I'm lined
up as jungle and Jays lineup is mid and
he was he was going back to me after the
kind of failed support experiment and
and so he picked victor who says go to
mid champion and the enemy team banned
him so he's not allowed to play victor
and so so he's picking rise this is an
actual champion in the game called rise
and a sponsor the same way that Jay
rises fell just without the J dash and
he's been practicing rise and now he's
got a nominee he wasn't ready to bust it
out on stream because he wanted a little
more proficient with it but now he just
locked him in so he's gonna play rise
I'm kinda reminded my eve experiment and
that did really well for us so Jay this
could be a J reyez playing rise I feel
might be a good thing amazing yeah um so
yes that's my little story um ok and
talk about the art world I think I think
the concept of course selling is a super
important almost more important than
than then a lot of other industries let
me just get my t-mo here and the idea of
course selling is you know what do you
you're selling what you stand for as
opposed to just selling your products or
services of the benefits associated with
it a lot of people can't understand art
you know you need to explain what your
art means right if I look at a painting
it might be hard for me just to say oh
that's a really good painting i'm going
to go buy that thing but if I know that
you so you know you left you left your
job and started to go all in on your on
yourself after nine eleven so I don't
know the theme is too
you like what your one word is what
you're all about if it's overcome if
it's challenge if it's you know
something around betting on yourself if
it's confidence if it's passion you know
whatever it is you know if you're
capturing that spirit of doing your
thing and being in the moment now and
not waiting for the future like if
that's what your theme is all about this
is that's what you did with your
business if that's expressed in your
paintings whatever is expressed like a
good painting a good piece of music you
know any piece of art is only great if
there's emotion in it right like a good
painter expresses emotion through their
art the challenges you can always see
that emotion if I'm emotional I get all
excited and I'm yelling i ranting you'll
see it very clearly you'll see it
clearly if you you know if there's a
singer who's singing their song and you
know you could tell they're almost on
the verge of breaking down because it's
so sad because it's a love song or it's
a it's you know they lost somebody you
feel that emotion with them painting is
harder because you you're you're pouring
your guts out onto this canvas and
you're having an emotional connection
and emotional reaction or you should if
you're I'm just going to paint the bird
today great like that that's you know
that's not your like you could do better
but the person seeing it can't
understand that connection and so it's
on you to explain it tell me what I'm
looking at tell me why you you're here
to do what you do and I get that you're
on a mission and you want to help people
and it comes across in your in your
message and your loving and consider it
and so letting people know that what is
the mission that you're on how do you
express it to the art so that I can own
a piece of that right so that if I am
you know the person who hasn't
himself yet or I want to continue to
remind myself to bet on myself and take
those risks or take that chance or
whatever it is that you stand for then
by having your thing on the wall that's
a constant inspiration to me mm-hmm but
if I don't know what I'm looking at is
just a nice piece of art you know it
looks nice then it's a lot harder to get
that sail and the impact that you want
like you can impact people through a lot
more than just making ten thousand
dollars a month right you can have
people through the work through whom
every time they look at like I walk in
here the the you know the people behind
me that those canvases that J reyez help
me actually make those mean something to
me and they're just faces on the wall
but the faces represent something they
represent something powerful to me when
I walk in the room your art needs to
represent something and it does to you
but you have to express that to others
so that I want to sign up and i want to
buy your thing because i know what you
stand for so core selling sent apply it
is powerful you know Evan and I know
everybody hears you talk about the well
not everybody those who keep following I
hear the core selling and I really I
just have to say like true its kind of
some silly but it really is truly like
the difference between you know I I
don't have this how do i go it having a
hard time speaking today silly research
cdse day okay I feel like one of the
things it's why I respect your your
approach ten times more than than what i
see in so many others because like these
i'm going to cut like an impact face
business I don't know if that term is
already out there but like when you're
going for impact first and foremost
which I know which is what
you're all about it's just so much more
powerful and and then you make decisions
not that you don't need money and and
that that obviously will be a natural
byproduct but when you put the impact
piece first Abby it's like the
difference in my opinion it's a
difference between a good than a great
business in an extraordinary business um
using using mark triggers word that I
like it Oh his word extra help yeah I
really think that is the huge difference
but people i don't think are willing
some time to wait for i think the impact
business might might not happen in the
same speed that a business would you
know like the goal of impact might take
longer than the goal of a ten thousand
dollars but be the power behind the
impact businesses so much greater I
don't know just some thoughts I think
it's I think it it's the way I want to
do things yeah and and even look at what
happened there right like she sent a lot
of love she didn't ask a question she
just wanted to spread some positive
vibes and say thank you so like maybe
gratitude is is her one word or
appreciation is very one word or
whatever right and what happened like we
then SAT and talked about how she might
be able to improve her business like she
had an impact on us through her comment
didn't ask for anything and received and
so leveraging that more like it was
appreciation or gratitude or again like
understanding what it is that you saying
for and then doing that as much as
possible good things will come far below
our team is losing already so let's see
how we do ah
okay it's an early start both of our
both of our characters both Jan and mine
scale pretty hard so we're not great
early but we're good late so if we can
install this game out we're going to
that's how we're going to win no your
wind conditions hey business to know how
you're going to win and play to that
we're going to win by hanging around and
winning the league game so that's what
we need to make sure we do hey speaking
of a impact I'm really excited to go
back and wash your influence or
marketing video because this is
something that we talk a lot in the live
stream is like how do you get on the
radar radar of influencers I'm super
excited to watch that and I'm kind of
curious to hear what she does anyway
that was at your site now yeah that was
a good chat it's worth going back and
watching we had a good live live
audience to on that it was it was ended
up being the only hang out the only
extra hang on i did yesterday but it was
fun i kind of miss it now it's like only
one hang out what's happening miss you
guys let's make this one count yeah but
I think it's like a perfect example of
like I don't know what she ended up
saying I you know I never heard anyone
officially say influencer marketing but
I know that one of the best ways to you
know connect with influencers is to just
be grateful tell them how you've
impacted them so it makes me think of
that video yeah I can't wait to another
thing we talked about the supplies that
kind of the artisan natives is using
your art as a way to express gratitude
or to stand out in a way that only you
can and I use the example of there was a
woman who wanted to get on
Gary Vaynerchuk radar and he just had
his new book out and she was she could
also sing and so she sang a book review
yeah right so I'm gonna get I'm gonna
get but Lina pink here Jane sister
hopefully they don't die um she's saying
a book review where everybody's giving
book reviews everybody saying how great
it is and on and on and on right so like
you're one of many awesome but she's the
only one that who was singing it and so
it's different and unique right makes
her stand up and so whatever your
talents are whatever your artistry is
inject that into the outreach and after
that conversation Alec Alec was over
during the day was listening in and he
was talking about how he wants he loves
Kevin Hart and wants to get on Kevin
Hart's radar and like he watches can
snapchat and you know it's like it's all
about Kevin Hart which is great and he's
trying to figure out how do we get Kevin
Hart to it's like it's my birthday
yesterday was Alex's birthday you think
of my message Kevin Hart and say hey
Kevin is like birthday he'll send me
like a message back maybe but like you
can do a lot better than that to where
you know kevin has a new movie that's
coming out I think it came out today I'm
not hundred percent sure but it's coming
out this weekend of a sign up today
already um you know Alex knows how to
salsa dance right so instead of just
making a video than anybody else can
make why not make a salsa dancing video
about his new movie coming up take the
theme song with the movie and do a salsa
routine or take you knows his fiancee
and flip her in the air to the theme
song like something that you saw would
be different so what everybody else is
doing right like he'll see that and said
this crazy kid from Canada's flipping
his wife all in the air and
no I don't know how Kevin Hart actually
talk so I'm just making that up but like
something that he was loved write
something that stands out is if somebody
you know if when people have made
tributes uh to me using their art their
art style I've always done my best and
try to kind of highlight and appreciate
them and showcase it off it stains out
where sometimes the comments don't like
you know the comment that we got today
that we highlighted was was extra
special and filled with love we also get
like I get a ton of those to which I'm
very fortunate about but when you go the
extra mile and put in you know like
there was there is a the blind artist
who made a piece of art for me you know
did a portrait of me you know that
stands out there's people who've written
songs there's the whole Evan man
spider-man song saga that I had to go
ahead to put an end to you because
people just kept going on with Evan man
Oh buddy um so just you know if you want
to stand out not just doing what
everybody else can do like I I could I
guess make it a painting of somebody but
it wouldn't be impressive but that would
Wow anybody because because I don't have
that skill but doing something that you
can do even if you don't have an
audience you know you don't have people
to promote them to doing something that
you can do based on your artistic
talents and you're talented at something
if you're a programmer you know make me
in Evan carica program or make the Kevin
Hart you know movie program app or some
of his favorite quotes or whatever it is
you know you can use your talents to
really stand out and show your
appreciation that gets you on the mouth
so there I don't know how we got onto
that segue but I liked it I liked it I
know says we she was talking about yeah
influencers the video right that's how
we got there you never know it's bad you
never know what's gonna happen on the
live stream Wow our team is losing so
badly at six to one I zoned out on that
conversation we dropped about a five
kills hey you got to stay in the present
Evan cup of finalists I was very much in
the now but we just lost another one so
we're Sutton yes is that what happens
when you're in the friends and
everything else phone is off dear lillie
j is 0 0 and 0 okay so it's it's a yeah
well we're we're we're battling guys
we're battling this is it let's see how
we do alright next question what we got
cool it was funny i have the same as out
I zoned out in what you were saying to
and I completely neglected to chat the
live chat so I'm just making sure we're
not missing anything there um and then
17 month does whatever game believe
someone singing in the chat and then my
last minute Louie if they know oh nice
Oh as long as I know oh ok alrighty so
next question come from oh wow they all
showed up I can't wait to read this one
Evan because of every once in a while we
get email like this and I just have to
read it because I I just have a cup of ?
anyway it says thank you my dear but I'm
looking for sponsorship to start my
business dear all right lots of deer
that was it quick i'm looking for a
sponsorship to start my business yeah
all right
so I don't I don't know yeah I don't
know what business you're in oh this is
from Patrick I just sorry I didn't say
the name sponsorship to start your
business well you know I think the main
thing that you want to think about if
you're looking for a sponsorship is that
you want to be as mindful about what bit
what is a value to them as much as you
want the value that they bring to you
they're obviously going to want a
relationship that is mutually beneficial
so that can be different things
depending on potential sponsors like in
YouTube sponsors are going to be
interested in things like your audience
how big your audience is you know are
they going to get is you is you is is
then sponsoring you going to get the
word out on them and then I know that
sponsors to they want to know that you
really care about you know about them
that you really do genuinely like what
they're doing and and the value their
product or whatever it is that they're
doing it's like they want to know that
you really do have a genuine interest in
seeing them succeed and that just comes
in my opinion from genuinely liking and
believing in what it is they do so it
depends on yeah I guess it just depends
on wool in terms of the details of how
to go after that I think it depends on
what business you're doing and but I
think those are some just foundational
things is what do you have to add value
to them and do you really like it do you
really like what what they are who they
are and what they are you know what
they're about as well
you took a different approach and I was
going to take so I just want to make
sure i'm thinking clearly can you read
the question back i know is super short
well I think it's just saying he just
made a statement I am looking for
sponsorship to start a business and I
think okay okay yeah okay you're not
going to get a sponsor to start your
business you need to go sponsor yourself
to start your business pre like it's
back to the funding you know issues from
before where like nobody's coming to
save your business you can't just not
start because there's no what happened
your lane your JS upset something's
happening come on someone do something
JS upset Oh almost got Top three sex um
like you need to go start you gotta find
a small wait to get started and not wait
for somebody to come and give you money
like nobody is coming to give you money
to start a business mm-hmm and so don't
sit there and wait for that to happen
before you do anything you got to go out
and hustle invest your time invest your
energy invest your heart invest your
hustled go try to get your first client
make a little bit of money poor that
back into the company make some more
money right um team the team the team
this is a the my teammates are now
intentionally killing themselves both is
going to be on this is going to be hard
one to pull through um but yeah and if
everybody watching like don't don't wait
and just try to find an investor you
have to go out and do it yeah you're not
getting startup funding you start
funding is your your heart
then it's because I don't want you to
waste your time and I don't want you to
do nothing which is what most people do
I'm not going to start my business until
and it's not just money until until
whatever until fill in the blank until
this happens i'm not going to start my
business and then that thing never
happens so you never start your business
yeah so if this is a dream of yours I
want to make sure that you actually can
do something about it so find the small
way and get started that's it's what I
get okay love it alright next question
comes from moneta don't you I'm 18 up
Juanita moneta says hi Evan I'm trying
my best to have start a startup company
a top and hair salon finding someone to
write a business plan became impossible
either I have any experience in this
industry or an MBA to write a business
plan I just jot down ideas which
basically described the purpose of the
project can you help me recommend a
person who can give me a consult
consultant service life is very
difficult in Bangladesh especially if
one is a woman so she's looking for
someone to consult her in regards to a
business plan she's in Bangladesh and
she's having a hard time finding that
next step of help all right um I think
you know uh there's so many other ways
to model the you know model people who
have who are doing what you're doing
even if they are not physically where
you are like it may not be that you can
find someone in Bangladesh who can write
it out for you but I guarantee
he with some time and research I you
know Evan you may have some people on
your channel I don't know if there's
anyone who's in the in that industry but
even if it's not specifically a hair
salon you can likely find someone who's
in just a similar market that you can
begin to learn right now how they did it
how they got started because I just
think that similar to the previous
question like we can think we have to
have all of this stuff in place before
we can start and I think that it's not
wrong to get a plan but I do think that
you have an ability to find out
information today by finding out what
other people have done and it's amazing
what you can do with with just hunger
and a desire to learn and the internet
but I think I think that's a good place
to start because you may not immediately
have this business plan figured out but
what I think you will learn is by
hearing what other people have done and
learning the business of the hair salon
via what others have done it what it
doesn't start to give you more ideas
specific to how you want to make an
impact and the more specific you are
about how your hair salon is different
and what you want to do differently and
uniquely the more you get to that I
think then the easier it will be to then
make a business plan because you'll know
exactly what you want to do and there
you go that's it the world according to
recent I like it I yeah I don't think
you should hire somebody to make your
business plan first of all it's
understanding there's a couple reasons
you want a business plan and so I don't
know if it's for your own like if you if
it's for you to actually run the company
or if it's because you're trying to get
investment business my for that or what
the reason is but here's here's why it's
here's why it's not great to have
somebody else rate your business plan
because you need to execute the business
plan and if you don't know enough to
write the business plan then you're not
going to enough to execute the business
plan and so what you really need to have
is more experiencing industry so
tarisha's point about wall and success
and finding you know getting some
experience the super important in my
master meeting last night I had a member
who was wanting to grow her business and
looking at a higher sales people i want
to i want to get somebody to go and sell
my stuff who's a big fight the chick an
i get there save j save j all right we
saved nikki probably to get out anyway
but i feel like i contributed Oh die die
yeah double kill team of work triple
triple triple kill t forget that yeah
team was doing work all right most
didn't work that was that was pretty
exciting there's um hey guys I zoned out
there is exciting okay so one of the
members one of the members was gonna
hire okay my I'm gonna expand by hiring
salespeople and that's how I'm gonna
grow my business and it can be a great
way to grow business nothing wrong with
with that necessarily just she doesn't
know she cheek doesn't sell and she
can't manage a sales person she wouldn't
know what to tell them like if it's not
going well she can't guide them and
mentor them and just wants that sales
person to me totally self-sufficient and
that's that's not going to happen you
know like a matching put your in that
position you're working for a boss who
can't give you any guidance or
mentorship and when you're failing is
basically just all on you to figure it
out
nobody wants to work for that person and
so it sounds like an easy solution but
it's not the thing that can work for her
so she needs to do something else and
luckily there's other strategies that
she can use that are more attuned to her
abilities that's what you'll have
success so you need to know how to make
the business of success right which a
business client that's basically what it
is right here is how my business is
going to be successful and if you don't
know I need to go hire somebody then you
will know how to execute on that plan
right like great here's his perfect
business plan but if you don't know how
to do the things in the business plan
then it's not going to work for you it's
going to be a waste of a waste of money
doing it and then also you know probably
a bigger waste of money because it's
going to call for you to spend money on
setting up this hair salon you don't
just set up a hair salon for free and if
you don't know what you're doing you're
going to make a lot of mistakes and lose
a lot of money and that I don't want to
happen for you so the answer is you need
to be able to get to the point where you
know enough about the business to build
to make the pie in yourself and have
confidence that's going to work out what
is that thresh doing our teammates are
there feeding their feeding hard like
intentionally feeding it's crazy what
does it anyway um yeah anyway so that's
my thought and I mean it ties into a
Rishi saying to you about go get some
experience and go met the go learn from
people who've done it if it's inside
your industry or some kind of related
field it's super important you got you
have to know you have to know that it's
going to work or at least have a pretty
good idea of how your business works
before you get into a business like hey
guys i'm going to start a t-shirt
business but i have no idea how to teach
your business works but i'm going to
spend money on t-shirts and everything
else
surround it yeah you know hopefully that
works out but I'm not sure you know um
this and it's not to make fun it's it's
care like I don't want you to lose money
I want this to work out for you I want
to see this hair salon be an amazing
success for you and so it may be going
to work for another hair salon at the
start learn to learn the industry have
some confidence that when you love is
going to be successful and then you can
write your own business plan so what are
you get hey hey all right we're gonna
catch at we got a lots of chatter lots
of chatter it looks like it's all
chatter chatter nothing specific to your
question so it's all good there any hi
to each other yeah everybody's chatter
chattering away overdue yeah all right
next question is coming from a vessel or
Cecil so you saw little sit peacefully
yeah Cecil says 'even folks who are well
my name is Cecil I mean I'm a firing
businessman I've been working on
creating and launching a mobile app for
the past three years that serves to
educate and to offer career guidance
services to south african youth I've had
the privilege to come across your
company services I studied Electrical
Engineering and currently working at the
compliance investigator in the insurance
industry I have an eye for detail I got
this burning desire to get the app off
the ground I would like you to mentor me
and help me build the app parenthesis
service agreement I'm looking forward to
hearing from you okay so yeah we get a
lot of app questions people ready to
launch and wanting different
of advice around the apps and I think
one of the things that we always always
always say is if you are wanting to you
know be successful in your app
absolutely make sure that you feel like
this app is is amazing and great because
just like anything else everybody's
making apps and a lot of them are not
good you know so make sure that it's an
app that you one hundred percent believe
in and that being said he said this was
like a three years ago plan generally
speaking how long does it take for one
I'm just asking I don't know Evan if you
of this answer is that like generally
how long does it take for one to
complete that process of developing a
new app I mean is it I guess it depends
on how complex the app are but I say
that because sometimes we can also fall
into the thing where we plan plan plan
plan plan and we never actually start
getting it and to mark it and so another
piece of advice that that we say is that
once you've had your app out make sure
you are supremely aware and attentive to
the users and how they are liking the
app so I have you already begun
providing a beta version that you can
start to get people using it and giving
you feedback because I think that's also
hugely valuable going back to the other
point with our last question like you
can plan plan plan and then put it out
there and like nobody's find it valuable
and so I think having it out there with
some users now is really valuable so
that you can start getting feedback and
make any adjustments or changes as you
go to make that appt great I get some of
the other questions are specific to you
even so I'll pass that
to you it's been three years of try to
do this app yeah that kind of got my
attention because I don't you know I
don't I don't develop apps software but
I I feel like that feels a little long
and am I wrong about that um yeah
probably no no you're not probably wrong
like like it's right it shouldn't take
that long oh hey got the kill team will
doing work I'm seven kills one death and
my one death was too I'm the monster
instead of an enemy team so so far oh
but I maybe talk to you soon i'm about
to die yeah t ma died very sad that's
what I get laid all I'm doing um listen
it's the right it's the right idea it's
you're wrong execution mm-hmm it's the
right idea it's a wrong execution and
the idea is to get help that is a long
time and what it basically means is like
this this this person doesn't have the
skills to do it whether it's actually
building it or marketing that feels is
something missing which I totally get
and understand I am NOT your partner for
this and so that's what you need to go
up and do is find who the right partner
is for this and stop waiting like three
years is a ridiculously long time get
out there and build it find the person
and go and build it
all these guys are rough here these guys
are rough so that's what i mean by right
right right idea just not the right
execution what are the skills that you
have that make it a fit you you know
you're really good at just coming up
with the app idea you're going to go up
marketing you're going to actually
develop it if you could develop it then
why haven't you developed it yet if you
can't develop it then you need to find
the person who can help you develop it
or do a different business where you
don't need a partner you can do it all
yourself you know like stop stop waiting
three years is three years of no action
is too long and then I love that you're
reaching out and that you're trying to
now go out and do it um but like i said
i am not the right partner for you and
so it's finding who that person is
somebody you know somebody somebody who
you have a relationship with somebody
who you can trust somebody who you know
you have the shared values with it you
feel the same vibe with the last thing
you want to do is make it jump into a
partnership with your with your baby
with the thing that you really want to
do with some total stranger who you have
no idea who they are right mm-hmm so I
love it I wish you tons of luck and
success it's the right idea you just got
to find the right person mm-hmm good
luck good luck single
okay next question is coming from
Russian right marcin assassin just like
I don't know that I don't know that I've
ever gotten a name on these dreams but I
mean I've heard so many names I've never
heard ever ever anywhere else this is
like i love it i thought my name was I
thought my name was unique but not the
only one okay hi Evan I had a quick
question I have prototyped an amazing
and truly unique app that people all
around the world will use every day like
one connect I think we may wait we just
lot our team surrendered so oh ok we got
this is a little longer so that might be
better then yeah that's okay well let's
see you let's see what our final stats
are here I don't want to rush the
question so let's see how we did yeah
yeah uh I got an S you know I got an ass
great wait I went seven and three the
team went uh what the team went nine and
31 Wow the team would nine and 31 it
happens it happens Rishi what's our what
do you want to what do you want to end
on what sorry she inspiration of the day
inspiration of the day is guys consider
consider an impact I'm that I like make
that word out that doesn't exist impact
an impact based business which again
going back to course selling versus a
business that's driven by I know it's
going to be you know I mean I'm not
saying don't don't want to be profitable
obviously that's what business is about
but consider impacts an impact business
where you can change the world
what why are you laughing look at this
didn't it didn't come out as profound
out of my mouth as it was in my head I
thought is pretty profound how those
feel in it okay that's way too serious
is going I like it okay yeah well that's
I was believing it I believe that all
right cool down all right well thanks
for the fun guys go jays go tonight
cheer them on eight o'clock eastern I
think something like that game one hands
and that we do um guys thank you so much
for joining in have an awesome close to
the week go crush Friday one more day
then the weekend is here and then we get
the crush monday again and start all
over thanks for the love and support
continue to believe or whatever your one
where it is and I'll see you soon